- [Instructor] The folks
you see in this picture
are two NASA astronauts
who also happen to be identical twins.
On the left here, this is Mark Kelly,
you can see his name on
his patch right over there,
and then this is Scott Kelly.
And the reason why we want to look
at these two astronauts in particular
is to think about genotype and phenotype
that we have been introduced
to in other videos.
So just as a bit of a review,
when people talk about genotype,
they're talking about the
actual genetic information
encoded in an organism's genes.
So, if you go inside a
cell we have chromosomes
and then on those
chromosomes, there are long,
each chromosome's a long stretch of DNA.
And then sections of
that long stretch of DNA
will code for various things,
often usually various proteins.
But there's a difference
between what is actually,
what information is in one's genes
versus what actually gets expressed.
The observable characteristics,
that is phenotype,
and two people with the same genotype
they might have a very similar phenotype
but they won't necessarily
have an identical phenotype
because above and beyond the
genes affecting phenotype,
you also have the environment
affecting someone's phenotype.
So, as you can see here,
Mark and Scott Kelly,
they're identical twins,
they have the same genotype.
But if you just look at
their facial characteristics
you can see that you could tell
the difference between the two,
and it's not just the fact
that Mark has a mustache
and that Scott doesn't, we
could draw in a mustache,
we would still see that
they look different.
And that's because their bodies
developed in different ways
based off the environment
that they happen to be in.
And this idea that the same genotype
could result in variations of phenotype,
this is known as phenotype plasticity.
Phenotype.
Phenotype plasticity.
And maybe in one of the
most extreme experiments
ever conducted on phenotype plasticity,
NASA was intrigued to see,
well, what would happen
to the gene expression
if Scott Kelly spent an
extensive period of time in space
while his twin brother didn't.
So they looked at how
their bodies expressed
certain characteristics before Scott spent
an extended period of time in space.
And then after he spent that time in space
they studied his body
and they saw that there was
differences in the mitochondria,
differences in which genes were expressed.
In fact, there was a 7%
difference in the gene expression
after the extended time
in space for Scott.
So that's the example of
that space environment
changing Scott's phenotype.
And the NASA scientists theorized
that it was a low oxygen environment
there was a lot of carbon
dioxide in that environment,
there were stressors from space travel
that would have affected how the genotype
which is identical to his
brother, Mark's genotype,
how it might have been expressed
resulting in the phenotype plasticity
above and beyond what
other changes in phenotype
between Scott and Mark accumulated
over the course of their lives
despite having the same
genetic information.